in a new federal lawsuit a chicago
family says police officers
forcibly entered the wrong home and then
pointed a gun at their children
an executive order from chicago's mayor
this year finally allowed the family to
obtain police body camera video
of the 2019 incident and we have to give
you a heads up this is very tough to
watch
it shows the officers with the guns
drawn searching the family's home
for suspects who had fled police dave
savini he's from our chicago station
that's wbbm
he broke this story
chicago police officers responded to a
911 august 2019
about two men fighting at a nearby gas
station one of them possibly armed
when officers arrived four men ran on
the pursuit officers entered this
apartment building
but there is no public evidence
suggesting this is where the suspects
ran
officers went to the third floor where
they kicked down the door
of this apartment belonging to regina
evans and steve winters
a lawsuit filed by the couple tuesday
alleges officers
forcibly entered their home without
announcing themselves as police
body cam video shows them holding
winters down as other officers checked
the apartment
the lawsuit alleges an officer had a gun
to winter's head
officer with the gun to my head i
thought it was kind of
over in one room they woke up a 73 year
old grandfather at gunpoint
and in another they find the couple's
children five-year-old rashaila
and nine-year-old savela they were in
their beds when they say an officer
entered their room and pointed a gun at
them
so what did you do when you saw the gun
i was crying i was hollering and i was
screaming and i was trying to figure out
what was going on
the other one put a gun in my face
the family later can be heard repeatedly
telling the officers the suspects
never entered their unit officers later
apologized
with a gun up here you know what i'm
saying in a statement a cpd spokesperson
said
the apprehension of fleeing suspects are
often active in fluid situations in
which
officers are balancing public safety and
the safety of all
individuals involved at all times
officers are expected
to conduct themselves in accordance with
the law and department policy
trauma heartache
they left a lot behind they left a lot
of baggage behind
for cbs this morning i'm dave savini
a lot of baggage is right fuel baggage
is watching that can you imagine how
traumatized those children are
yeah and heinz science 2020 but to hear
that the police
went into that apartment without knowing
with no evidence that he
that they had even gone in the apartment
was very frightening made that decision
to
to bust down the door not walk in an
open door but bust it down that's to be
a better way to do this
dave savini again with another exclusive
look on that little girl's face told you
exactly